dont sa mesure emblématique et très
controversé d'interdiction de manifester
prononcée par un préfet une vingtaine
peut être une trentaine même de député
en marche vont s'abstenir de voter le
texte
alors donc sans doute pas une grosse
front mais un signal quand même pour
emmanuel macron on va d'abord écouter
gilles legendre patron du prêt du groupe
lrm à l'assemblée il relativise on
écoute je ne suis pas là pour pratiquer
la police de la pensée
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
liberté de vote dans le groupe ne soit
pas le sujet de vote l'abstention ça
n'est pas un vote contre je ne peux pas
dire que d'un côté la démocratie doit
respirer et notamment la démocratie
respirer entre le parlement et
l'exécutif et de l'autre côté brandir la
sanction à la moindre écart de valeur
mais alors on fait bien d'en parler car
le texte vient d'être votée à
l'assemblée avec 387 voix pour on n'a
pas encore le décompte exact des
marcheurs qui se sont abstenus ou pas
première question et juan o
il a raison c'est de le joindre en dix
ans la démocratie doit respirer c'est un
drame c'est à erwan que je m'adresse
chrétiens oui la raison de la démocratie
pouvoir respirer par clairement elle à
la démocratie aux parlementaires ou par
le à l'assemblée nationale mais c'est
pas nouveau ça fait des années que dans
les gènes de la caution de la vème
république
renforcée par les dernières réformes que
le parlement et au pas et il est là pour
être pour valides pour être une chambre
d'enregistrement de ce que fait le que
décide l'exécutif prenne la république
d'abord près ministre ensuite donc
évidemment la démocratie respire pas
beaucoup au parlement d'autant plus
aujourd'hui qu'on a une majorité c'est
pas le fait de l'hérault m en
particulier mais s'il ya une majorité
écrasante des oppositions qui sont
divisés et à qui on laisse relativement
assez peu de place pour autant est ce
que il leur laisse vraiment donc il ne
laisse pas de glace pas de
cet espace aujourd'hui à ses propres
députés quand il dit s'abstenir c'est
pas voté qu'on sait pas voter quand nous
sommes enfin c'est en tout cas montrer
qu'on n'est pas convaincu il ya
aujourd'hui de ce que disent des
parlementaires et de la majorité de
l'opposition assez peu de débats au
parlement assez peu de liberté qui est
laissé au débat y compris au sein des
valeurs om là ce qu'on voit le fait
qu'ils aient d un salon de l'abstention
ou dire qu'on n'a pas encore le décompte
mais ça montre au moins une certaine
réticence voie de la tension au sein du
groupe et pour le coup je pense que
c'est plutôt une bonne chose que cette
loi est une et pas elle n'est pas un bon
signe pour la liberté publique
on reviendra c'est peut-être sur le fond
de la loi alexis s'est effectivement est
ce qu'aujourd'hui emmanuel macron et
objets donner un peu d'oxygène quand
même malgré tout à ses troupes on sait
moins sévères est moins ferme comme
propos qu'au moment de débat sur la loi
immigration ou là on disait aux députés
attendent il n'a pas le choix enfin donc
vous avez là suffisamment d'ennuis comme
ça faut pas au plus ouvrir un front avec
sa majorité il se trouve effectivement
c'était déjà le cas sur la loi de
l'immigration c'est à nouveau le cas sur
cette voie là qu'une étude il ya une
partie qui est plus à gauche intérieure
dhs en marge et historiquement c'est une
chose puis à une autre qui je pense a
pas été convaincue par les explications
du gouvernement sur cette affaire
et c'est vrai que nous allemands est pas
absolument convaincant et j'aime quand
on voit semble de mesures ont dit bon
bah on va donc pas ce que vous dites on
va parler du fond après mais c'est un
peu difficile de ne pas en parler parce
que c'est pas non plus une affaire
colossal du point de vue de la forme du
point de vue du fond quand on dit on va
imposer c'est pas normal que les
manifestants dissimulent leurs visages
ça me paraît de bon sens semaine
effectivement le droit de manifester est
garanti il n'y a pas de raison de cacher
son visage si ce n'est qu'on veut
commettre des exactions des saccages de
trucs comme ça ça je comprends
en revanche l'idée d'arrêter les gens
avant même qu'ils aient fait quoi que ce
soit parce que le préfet l'aurait décidé
samedi sur l'idée de dire que des gens
qui participeraient à une manifestation
serait financièrement responsable des
dégâts commis par d'autres
alors là ça me paraît qu'à mon avis ça
passe pas la barre du conseil
constitutionnel cette affaire là ça me
semble pas tenir debout contestable sur
le fond et dans la forme et ce
qu'effectivement signe d'une division
qui pas dramatique mais qui est quand
même
hélas oui mais qui est problématique en
fait parce que un jour il faut avoir des
principes et des valeurs simples à une
des difficultés je pense d'ailleurs de
cette majorité c'est que les français
ils ont signé sur un contrat qui disait
nous les pragmatiques on regarde les
réalités on a les genres en guise a
l'air pas mal ça mais en fait il ya
beaucoup d'indicateurs qui montrent que
je siècle qui commence a besoin de
valeurs et la ceiba leur contre-valeur
on ne fait pas de dégâts on ne casse pas
quand on manifeste ou bien on ne met pas
entrave à la liberté de manifester et
être un peu entre les deux finales c'est
je pense que à terme ça finit par créer
un manque par rapport à un alignement
qui a qui doit être dans la netteté et
je trouve que beaucoup de nos
compatriotes pensent qu'il ya un manque
de netteté auquel s'ajoute en plus la
position des marcheurs qui commençait
enfin comment on peut s'abstenir en fait
souci ces valeurs contre-valeur c'est
pas l'abstention qui n'est pas là il ya
un doute sur l'utilité aujourd'hui du
parlement qui est très préjudiciable
évidemment que l'assemblée nationale
c'est là sont utiles dire que les
députés sont des gens qui exercent leur
liberté en ne s'exprimant pas voilà
encore le message me semble un peu
ambigu donc sur le court terme ce
dimanche ça peut donner une respiration
pour ceux qui s'intéressent à au
fonctionnement et que 0 effectivement il
ya du jeu
je pense que les français qui ont pas
beaucoup de patience pour rentrer dans
les détails ce 10 mai à quoi croit-il
ces gens s qui est ce qu'ils ont
vraiment un socle mais un des arguments
alexandre que c'était du côté du
gouvernement c'est à dire mais justement
on empêche les empêcheurs de manifester
on retire des manifestations les 300 ou
quelques centaine de black blocks et
autres qui oui c'est un sophisme habile
mais pour répondre d'abord à la question
qui était posée sur la majorité je crois
que paradoxalement il aurait besoin
d'avoir quelques fondeur emmanuel macron
quand il était très fort dans l'opinion
et qui pouvait se permettre tout tout
tout ce qu'ils voulaient c'était bien
d'avoir une majorité de godillots là il
aurait besoin de gens qui ont une vraie
surface politique a un vrai sens
politique
parfois pour le protéger de lui-même et
de ses erreurs on parlera tout à l'heure
du référendum jeudi je pense que là ils
auraient besoin d'avoir une
majorité plus structurée avec une vraie
colonne vertébrale ensuite sur le fond
de la loi moi je pense que c'est pas
forcément une loi liberticide j'ai pas
l'impression d'avoir un état aujourd'hui
il père autoritaire hyper liberticide
d'autant plus que c'est le type de loi
qui est déjà utilisé pour les hooligans
dans le football cela dit je pense c'est
une loi qui va très mal passé dans
l'opinion parce que encore une fois il
semble y avoir deux poids deux mesures
le gouvernement joue d'un côté la carte
du parti de l'ordre et de l'autre côté
on a la sphère benalla qui continue qui
souvenez-vous il me restait quand même
des gens dans une manifestation de
l'autre côté on a le député madjid el
guerrab ex-député en marche qui a
fracassé à coups de casque un collègue à
l'assemblée nationale qui aujourd'hui
siège dans une commission d' enquête
contre les violences de l'extrême droite
donc voilà il ya un côté absurde dans
tout ça avec un gouvernement qui joue la
carte de la fermeté mais je crois qui
apparaît en total décalage avec la
réalité que les françaises vivent au
quotidien notamment dans certains
quartiers où il ya une violence
quasiment structurelles et rayonnant
alexandre disait pas liberticide et vous
étiez moitié acquis convaincre sur
alexandrie on n'est pas dans un état
autoritaire niait liberticide alors je
pense qu'il ya pas mal d'arguments qui
pourrait contribuer à démontrer
qu'aujourd'hui la vénère le pouvoir
exercer et relativement autoritaire dans
sa philosophie très ascendante et pas
on ne favorise pas l'émergence ou non le
nil débat ni lait ni les contre pouvoirs
et ensuite sur cette loi en particulier
si ce jour ce qui était dit alors que
dans mes cours de droit quand j'étais
étudiant m'avait appris que en termes de
en matière de police administrative la
liberté était la règle et la contrainte
ou l'interdiction l'exception la même si
on peut le justifier par quelques cas on
est c'est pas le cas de quelques black
blocks qui est en cause c'est la
philosophie du doute de la loi qui est
appliquée on est sur un renversement
d'ailleurs qu'on va on renverse un droit
dans lequel jusqu'à maintenant il faut
avoir commis une infraction pour ce
faire pour être poursuivi
là on va avoir un droit qui un résident
de part en part par présomption
exactement comme quand vous lutte mais
aussi ses versets c'est la déclinaison
dans les manifestations d'un d'une
société de précaution et de prévention
qui est qu'est-ce qui applique ses
principes mais pas uniquement à ce
domaine majeur c'est la même chose qu'on
avait le principe de précaution dans la
constitution sur la question économique
c'est la même chose quand on a un la
multiplication de réglementation est
dans une société qui de plus en plus
refuse le risque refuse d'incertitude et
donc va tout interdire par principe en
amont et de ce point de vue là peut-être
que j'ai remué le principe de précaution
on se on se prémunit d'une menace
potentielle d'un risque là d'une réalité
avérée c'est à dire que les saccages on
les a vus donc c'est pas que théorique
on sait qu'il ya des gens qui viennent
pour casser pour en découdre la question
est est ce que ces moyens là sont le
meilleur moyen ou est-ce qu'il y en
avait d'autres et peut-être j'en aurais
tu lui d'autres mais dire que ça relève
de la précaution en l'air
kallas je crois par action ne rend pas
été comme quand ça dépend on crée
nouvelle faction qui est de se
dissimuler le visage donc ça ça devient
une infraction pour l'interdiction
manifester interdiction d'y rester ces
prêts d'en tisser préventif
c'est sensé s'appuyer sur tango de
constatation antérieur et c'est comme
susceptible d'un recours devant le juge
bon je reconnais que c'est fragile
en revanche l'idée de détendre un
périmètre de contrôle
ça me paraît le bon sens même que la
police ait le droit de contrôler les
gens pour éviter qu'ils aient des armes
par destination ou des armes tout court
dans leur sac
quand on a vu ce qu'on a vu ça ça me
paraît normal donc c'est pour ça que ça
me paraît difficile à mon sens et n'est
évidemment pas une loi liberticide ça me
paraît difficile de dire c'est ou tout
bien ou de mal il faut regarder chacun
des articles amont s'agit d'un certain
qu'ils vont de soi il y en a d'autres
mais moi le plus choquant c'est ce que
la responsabilité collective
moi je ne pense pas que quelqu'un puisse
être responsable cuisine dans ses rangs
de quelque chose au seul motif qu'ils
participent à une manifestation parce
que sinon il faut interdire les
manifestations quelques réactions de nos
internautes
nicole nous dit je suis contre cette
entrave à la liberté de manifester
c'est au juge de prendre des décisions
même si la justice n'est pas toujours
impartial de mon point de vue ajoute
elle monsieur babineau qui nous a
rejoint aussi c'est une loi liberticide
anticipé le délit d'un individu sur la
base de soupçons ce n'est pas acceptable
et cij qui complète ses taux jugent de
restreint les libertés à personne
d'autre on va peut-être passer à notre
autre sujet qui est finalement aussi lié
au gilet jaune et au grand débat c'est
celui du référendum puisque emmanuel
macron a donc émis l'hypothèse d'un
organiser un pour clore la séquence du
grand débat depuis les questions se
multiplient à quelle date doit avoir
lieu ce référendum doit-il être couplée
avec les élections européennes sous
quelle forme doit-il être présenté aux
français s questionnaire à choix
multiples vous avez certainement tous un
avis là dessus on commence avec le vôtre
alors d'abord effectivement emmanuel
rivière sur les modalités peut être
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de ce qu'on
attend de ce référendum est ce qu'il
faut qu'ils soient organisées en même
temps que les élections européennes
première question je pas sûr que les
français eux mêmes et est un avis ça
peut paraître effectivement comme une
bonne occasion andré tous les électeurs
sont convoqués au moment d'une forte
abstention après tout autant tout mettre
ensemble et puis ça pourra motiver les
gens pour aller voter voilà ça pourra
motiver les gens pour aller voter
la question cod pourquoi parce que ces
élections européennes c'est quand même
une occasion importante qu'il se produit
tous les cinq ans que tous les cinq ans
de parler un petit peu d'europe et de se
poser des questions sur l'engagement
européen de la france et ce projet
collectif
faut dire on y va on n'y va pas on y va
de quai de quelle manière et cette
élection c'est le parent pauvre de notre
système électoral 42 % de participation
la dernière fois en france et en europe
d'ailleurs le taux de participation en
europe t exactement similaire en moyenne
à celui de la france avec en plus une
un fléau qui s'appliquent
systématiquement à l'élection européenne
c'est que c'est une élection dans la des
lectures et détournée de son objet on
regarde qui est en tête qui a doublé qui
dans les compétitions de haut vol à plus
ou moins 5 % etc et on oublie tout ça
saigne et envoyé en des députés au
parlement européens qui vont siéger dans
des groupes les gens ignorent d'ailleurs
qui est le groupe majoritaire au
parlement européen donc il ya un petit
problème donc c'est une élection qui
bénéficierait d'un appui de
participation et qui pâtirait lourdement
qu'on parle d'autre chose
à ce moment là maintenant est-ce que
d'abord je reviens tout petit peu en
arrière bonne idée ou pas de proposer un
référendum pour sortir je suis
honnêtement assez partagé je suis assez
convaincu que le grand débat pour qu'il
ait une utilité doit déboucher sur une
décision politique et une partie est un
événement politique
un appel avec talkie walkie et fasse
intervenir les citoyens parce que sinon
c'est juste une opération de com et voir
une campagne électorale
du gouvernement pour autant est-ce que
le référendum est la bonne solution
j'ai du mal à le croire a priori je vois
pas exact parce que des pages de quoi
sur quoi on va voter de quoi on va
débattre et jeu et le sujet pour moi
n'est pas de remettre en scène le
gouvernement c'est de remettre leur
mettre suffisamment en selle pour qu'ils
puissent réaliser des réformes
ensuite pour poursuivre une politique si
vous faites d'un référendum vous gagnez
1 il peut potentiellement le gagner à un
moment donné en empruntant 2019 mais
c'est pas ça qui lui donne une majorité
pour continuer son action jusqu'à la fin
donc je suis assez sceptique franchement
plutôt du côté défavorable un piège
tendu à ses adversaires par emmanuel
macron façon habile de s'en sortir je
tends dieu lui-même mousseline noire est
frappant bref à voir dans cette histoire
c'est comme absolument inouï on parle
d'un référendum faut-il un référendum
comment le référendum quand le
référendum en même temps que telle
élection pas en même temps que tu
élections